the idea of the stock actually came up
in an incubator
is called silicon catalyst I'm gonna
talk a little bit about that right that
we started a few years ago in 2015 some
of you may have been there right there
was a big party of the Avaya Stadium
which has the incredible property of
having the largest bar in Silicon Valley
if you have ever been there right it's a
very very long bar and they were about
six to eight hundred people there and
their problem we're trying to address
was the lack of startups and chips and
every healthy ecosystem needs startup so
I didn't and it looked like
semiconductors had become commodities
nobody was investing in them VCF moved
on there was no interest in so and so
forth and here we are now three and a
half years later and things have changed
right and so and what I'm going to do in
the next 50 or 60 minutes is to give you
a an overview right of where our
semiconductor so is not a lot of deep
technical knowledge in this but and
pleasement partly with questions and and
in perspective in that perspective I'm
also going to talk about EDA which is
what actually enables this right and I
guess I'm going to address the question
how is this monetized and and how much
is in there in in addition to doing that
right talking about EDA in the context
of semiconductors I will enter talk with
a shameless propaganda for a class that
we give here ie 292 a where which you
can join in spring if you want to learn
more about these things right and I'm
also going to talk a little bit about
silicon catalyst which is incubator that
incubates companies that wants to do
chips and so if you have a startup that
wants to do a chip and FPGA or anything
related to semiconductors right that's a
good place to go so without further ado
where are we in semiconductors this is
sort of a state-of-the-art chip done in
seven nanometer technology it's the
Apple our 12 it has seven billion
transistors it has a lot of what is
called intellectual property IP which
are pre-designed blocks right so you see
things there like CPUs
gpus these days of course NP use neural
processing units etc etc that's all put
together you get to seven billion
transistors which is remarkable it's not
the largest chip out there today but
it's unremarkable right it's in every
new generation Apple cell phone iPhone
and it means that the software that you
need to design this right needs to be
able to handle off the order of a
trillion polygons if you have seven
billion transistors right you have
interconnect divisions this is a bunch
of shapes the things get get fractured
right meaning they're decomposed into
all your rectangles so it's it's it's
fair to say that you'll have between one
and ten trillion polygons that you have
to be able to handle right so it's a
it's a fairly complex and thing to
design and I think the software is not
two notes behind right this is that was
bottom note I think it's a well capable
of doing that see there's another chip
this came out last year right it's and
the latest Nvidia chip and and this is
interesting because you see that this
packaging actually at the silicon level
this is a GPU that has eight hundred and
fifteen square millimeters 21 billion
transistors done in 12 nanometers so
slightly larger technology and it uses
300 watts so it's it's it's a lot of
power that goes in there and it
surrounded by for a high bandwidth
memory stacks which I have four gigabyte
each right and they're all put onto a
thing called the silicon interposer
which is sort of a mini board right
where you where you put all the things
and that and connects them so you can
see right these are the memory parts
there four of them right and the GPU is
in the middle so that's the kind of
thing that we can do with cinnamon
Tetris today if you wanna see where are
the largest chips being done it's sort
of nice to look at the at the history
right if we start with processors right
in the year 1971 the Apollo guidance
block which was done with discrete chips
because
didn't trust their and they had to start
before right in if you're candid about
it right and the Intel 404 had about
2300 transistors and it had 12 square
millimeters was a small chip right but
the Apollo guidance block had 4,000 and
103 and put North which were on several
boards right in this where integrated
circuits but not computers right every
chip had one nor we have come a long way
probably the CPU or at least the one you
can find online with most transistors is
one done by Graff core which is a
British startup that is doing processors
for artificial intelligence for machine
learning has 23 point six billion
transistors done in 16 nanometers right
so it's a pretty gigantic ship right 825
square millimeters in FPGAs the largest
one is Everest that holds a record right
and that's again not one shape it's it's
four or six chips that are put on a
silicon interposer otherwise you don't
get yield fifty billion transistors in
total and in GPUs right I showed you the
the Volta CPU right which was done last
year right there's a new one that has a
few less transistors by the same order
of magnitude twenty billion transistors
so that's the state of the art how did
we get there in case somebody hasn't
heard about it right Moore's law that
was originally the original paper by
Moore which essentially stated that the
number of transistors that you can put
on a chip right if you graph the
logarithm of that it's straight line so
it grows exponentially around the same
time a little bit less known rocks law
sometimes also course more second law
stated that every four years the cost of
a fab doubles right so that went along
today we are at about I showed you what
we can do in terms of transistors state
of the art fab costs about twenty
billion right there the one that that
Samsung built a few years ago was forty
billion dollars that's published as we
are around 20 billion that's the order
of Magnus
so and and the third thing that happened
and it was pretty amazing right was
Dennard scaling button art wasn't happy
and fellow and he noticed that as
transistors gets smaller right they get
faster and they use less power and so
empower which is proportional to the
square of the voltage times the
frequency the power density stays
constant if you shrink things as the
voltage goes down right and so I'm
essentially you can build ships and use
the same amount of power but are faster
right the transistors get smaller
unfortunately that ended about ten years
ago Dennard scaling didn't go on because
of leak actually if they make things too
small you don't have just dynamic power
which is a formula that you have there
you also if leakage power this leakage
between the gate and the substrate and
it's also leakage between drain and
source and the substrate or among them
right and so and that ended right
another problem if you scale voltage is
too far down it's of course noise you
cannot do this
arbitrarily right so we are at the
fraction of evolved today 0-8 volts you
know saying both it's very hard to go
down and so ten years ago the frequency
stop scaling because the nards scaling
and that right and the power and started
becoming a real problem right but the
number of transistors still went up
right and up to today and so the
question is of course when will that
stop it has to stop at some point and of
course it would switch technology we
could use something that is not silicon
that that is even smaller right but for
the time being that doesn't seem likely
the endless near has been proclaimed for
for many many years right as early as
1997 people were saying we're very close
to the fundamental limits of physics and
so and so forcing them that has not
happened but what has happened right is
that Moore's law has slowed down if you
look at this graph right it doesn't look
like it right these are these are sort
of all the chips up to 2016 it doesn't
include the last two years but if you
look at what
particular application which has been
the killer app of the last 10 years
right before that it was PCs in the last
10 years it has been smart phones cell
phones you cannot really see that that
has scaled and I learned the number of
transistors there but their technology
actually quite nicely and we have gotten
a new chip every year that technology
has been going down and if you want to
see how the that's a picture of each of
them right they were all roughly the
same size but in smaller and smaller
technology if you scale these if you
assume they are all in the same
technology right that sort of depicts
the number of transistors or you get
more and more and more transistors of
course we shrunk it so they were all the
same size and the a4 and if you look at
the number of transistors actually we
got roughly one point 38 X per year
that's not 2 X per year right but 138
expert years is pretty good that's what
cell phones have been able to do and if
you look at the performance right we've
also gotten a healthy improvement in
performance mostly through parallelism
right not through cranking up the clock
too much right all the things run at
gigahertz not at tens of gigahertz or
whatever and so em cell phones have kept
up but this has been a heart effort this
is a slide from synopsis right they see
pretty much all the design starts that
are there and so you have a number of
design starts there and every technology
starting in 2003 when we were doing 90
nanometers and you see the important
thing here and there's sort of a node
and a sub node in each of these graphs
right if you if you look at the yellow
bars which sort of shows you the length
before the next node takes over right
where so we start here a hundred designs
right in nineteen an ohmmeter so here
you a lot of hundred designed 65 and so
on this is getting longer and longer and
there's a few design starts at five
nanometers if you look carefully right
seven nanometers are quite a few but it
has slowed down it's not happening ever
here anymore right and this takes
several years so so I think that it's
safe to say that we've
able to keep Moore's law alive so far
but with heroic efforts this is the
latest right this is a EUV stepper and
extreme ultraviolet stepper which
actually resolves features using 13.5
nanometer wavelength slight that's
extremely traditional steppers right
that the traditional Authority uses 193
nanometers which is a factor of about 15
right it's it's a big factor yeah no I
want yeah now when I start to point out
here right is that the industry's done
heroic efforts to actually been able to
scale to this point right and seven
nanometers has few layers that are done
in extreme UV one of these machines cost
119 million dollars right it weighs
about a hundred tons and so and it took
many many many years to get there where
is even more impressive is that if you
want to move it right you need six
airplanes to do that right and so it has
to be designed so that it can be
disassembled so you can actually put it
in a plane right and six pieces and you
probably recognize this right if you're
Dutch this is ship hold right SM Ellison
Maryland you know where the plane is
going right it's so M so this this this
is being heroic and we've been able to
keep upright and increasing the cost and
and doing incredible technology right
but there is going to be compute
computing after Moore's Law and so if
you look at what is coming it's actually
not all that surprising right and the
World Economic Forum publish
this right this is a fellow chief
architect from hewlett-packard slap
right and he says well neural networks
will replace programming everybody has
to throw that in right everything it's
machine learning artificial intelligence
and so and so forth it's something to
that and there's more and more
communication done in photos that has
sort of already happened right all the
backbone of the internet that carries
most of the information is of course
fiber but it's moving to the data center
right now right I think that that's the
big thing there then special-purpose
computation elements will replace
generic general-purpose one that's good
because you could argue that there were
only two designs on the planet in terms
of processors right the ARM processor
which is in all cell phones right in the
Intel architecture which is in all the
data centers and everything else is sort
of virtually coexistence by by having
this less generic elements there's going
to be or the race as we speak right a
resurgent in design and this is driven
essentially through the things that are
here right which is artificial
intelligence and then of course IOT and
a lot of photonics also right and that
I'll show you some statistics in a
minute and data will be distributed not
hoarded in server farms and and and the
edge and the core will be a continuum
right there and this gentleman claims
that most data is actually just going to
be on the edge and we'll never make it
to the core that makes sense because
we're accumulating so much data right
that a lot of it has to be processed was
generated in this sort of way right
you're not interested in in having
persistent data so what does it mean for
the cools right let me now switch to EDA
the lesson of hardware right being that
Moore's Law has carried us to this point
it has slowed down it's probably going
to slow down even more it seems very
difficult to move at least with that the
cost involved today much beyond of where
we are today five nanometers not because
this technology boss is technologically
impossible but because the cost goes up
too much right and and
there's just no application I mean we
sell about a billion cell phones a year
right that's sort of the killer app but
there's not a lot of applications so you
can sell expensive billions of expensive
chips a year right there ISM there is
some some cheap ones like sensors invest
and stuff but those are very small so
because of the economies of scale the
economy of not having enough scale right
it's likely that Moore's law will end
around of where we are today nobody
likes to talk about that because that
makes industry a very different industry
then you're getting better and better
things every two or three years so
designing is somewhat similar to
programming the old dream of design
automation was to do something like a
silicon compiler there was a lot of talk
of that in the 90s right so you would
write down your circuit you press a
button this thing would compile and
instead of getting an executable that
runs in the computer you will get a chip
that you can print right and then do
your print and surprisingly we have made
progress going towards that right and
the typical flow starts at a so called
high level where the languages that you
use are C C++ like write this one called
system very log just one called VHDL and
so on the one that is most used system
very long and a lot of these high-level
synthesis programs also you C or C++ as
an input
you know synthesis which is akin to
compilation and generate you generate a
so called
register transfer level description this
is a description for synchronous
circuits so the model is your storage
elements or registers right that store
information you transfer the information
by changing it that's your combinational
logic right and then you write it again
into a storage element that's just a
finite state machine or a more fancy way
of describing a finite state machine and
and that is the model from which you
synthesize all did
circuits and so the languages to ordeal
and watch right it's it's probably 90%
95% of design at this level is done in
very lock right so naturally standard
and it's a language that describes that
abstraction which is essentially finite
state machines but with the data with
this and store action memories and so on
and so forth and it's what it's used for
essentially all these IDEs and then you
take that you do placement and routing
so you do logic synthesis right and um
and um generate a circuit and the
circuit is stored even today mostly in a
format called GDS - which is an ancient
form at a show in the history of EDA and
whence comes from writers 4050 years old
it's an effective standard right and so
and after you have generated this mass
and that is this physical synthesis or
placement and routing right if you paid
every element if you have a NAND gate
put it somewhere on the chip and then
connect it to wherever easily connected
if you have a billion of the things
right obviously it's a complicated
problem if you have two or three it's
it's a fairly simple problem and then M
you come to tape out which is what
everybody that is designing a chip and
dreams off right and tape out is
essentially generating this GDS file
that that contains all the geometrical
data which you can give to the shop that
will do the masks right and so on you
manufacture the thing right you a set of
masks you can think of like photographic
negatives or something and the
information for the mass writer is what
comes out of the MK pout and so M what
was simplified if you dig a little bit
deeper right it's actually fairly
complicated set of tools the electronic
system design alliance lists over 30
categories of idiot goes right the es da
is actually the lobbying group right
association to which all EDA vendors
belong and they publish market data
every quarter right and then they
classify all these tools according to
some kind of some kind of taxonomy and a
list
30 categories of EDA tools but you can
you can separate them into analysis and
synthesis so in synthesis essentially
you're compiling things you take an
initial description which is not very
detailed right and at the end of the
synthesis flow you generate this
trillion polygons right that are the
masks right which are going to fabricate
the things it's not totally automatic
sometimes this details missing that you
have to enter am certainly if you want
to optimize the circuit for example you
synthesize a circuit from a see
description and you want to correct the
timing it needs to be faster or whatever
then you have to intervene right and
enter additional information say this is
a critical path I want this thing to be
so faster so slow etc in parallel to
that and I think that this is very
different right here you could see
perhaps some analogy with software
particularly if you're writing if you're
writing many threats the only difference
I said what you synthesized in the end
is a two-dimensional thing right so
there's a lot of geometry involved in
graph theory right involved in the end
but what is really different is the
verification flow right even though we
use simulation you see their system
logic circuit simulation which is akin
to execute any program right so you have
a program you write a description and
you simulate that meaning you execute it
and see what would this do at the lower
levels there's all kinds of verification
that you typically don't do when you do
software right it's things like static
timing analysis so you're a description
you see you want to know how slow is it
going to be or how fast is it going to
be so the way to do it is you take the
logic circuit and you find the critical
path in terms of delays through the
thing and compute it you say well that's
simple right finding a path through a
graph doesn't sound that difficult it is
difficult because because it's false
path this process that never get enable
to write and those are difficult to find
and and the timing models themselves are
not that simple you do power analysis
you want to know before you felt the
thing how much power is the thing going
to use right what is the peak and that
is
of course not a number right but it's
just thing that fluctuates depending on
what it's doing and then even where the
cycle is right you want to make sure
that all this polygons the layout the
artwork that we're generating is correct
so for that particular fob so you need
design rules things that tell you the
metal pitch right the separation between
two metal lines needs to be this if you
have a contact over a metal line there
needs to be a certain amount of overlap
right and tolerance because the machines
are not perfect and for a modern process
you have many thousands of rules five
six thousand rules right that we have to
check so all the geometry that we
generate needs to be according to a
check and etc etc so the analysis part
of this the verification part if you
want is much more developed than than
than in the case of software and the
reason is of course that if you make a
mistake if you make a single mistake and
you have a chip that doesn't work you
have just thrown away many millions of
dollars right in preparing a mask that
fabrication etc is very hard to debug
right so and so even though this happens
right not every chip works out correctly
at first step out the the hip trade is
after the remarkably high right I mean
you you really verify and simulate the
things to death so that you can be
pretty sure that that what you're
designing is correct so many tools not
just a few for a small industry if you
want to look a little bit deeper right
and segment the things right there's
five segments that this industry
association the ESD a list right
intellectual property which is a segment
that didn't exist thirty years ago right
and and by now it's sort of the largest
one which are pre-designed blocks and
they're put in a library so if you wanna
if you design anything right it's likely
to have a USB it likes it's likely to
have a 2.4 gigahertz tax so that you can
do Bluetooth and Wi-Fi and things like
that there's no differentiation in
designing that and so what designers do
is you buy this block
right and just put them in your design
right you don't design them again and so
the name that stick with this is
intellectual property so they call them
IP blocks right and what they're talking
about is the USB memory right you don't
design memory right that's that's a
commodity it's known how to do it and so
on it's a force the largest IP block or
the largest IP company ant alerts that
we companies of course CPU itself and
the most successful company where
fathers are right arm or most cellphones
or perhaps also food so I have in our
core in there right and somewhere the
next category is printed circuit boards
they are just included here right you
have to put strips on the board and
sounds for sweet this is pretty
complicated these days but I'm not going
to talk about that the next two
categories are what is known as as EDA
proper right it's called computer aided
engineering and IC design and
verification what it is is that number
three Google engineering is anything
that is transistor level and above
transistor level you deal with logic
gates system level and so on and so
forth
and IC design and verification is a
physical design right once you want to
generate layouts art word masked right
that's called IC design and verification
right there's a data explosion of course
why do get more and more data as you go
down and so M that is that is difficult
and it's separated right like that for
historical reasons and then there's of
course services right and if you are
wondering how big are the segments and
IP is the largest one all right
semiconductor IP 36% of all dollars
mainly da are done selling pre-designed
blocks then computer-aided engineering
right which is CAE which is design at
the logic level at the system level and
the transistor level is also about one
third a little bit smaller and then IC
design and verification which is once
you have a logic these are
convert the thing and two into a mask
right into artwork that you can send its
placement and routing essentially it's
2020 is two percent the total revenue of
the industry in the last four quarters
just reached ten billion actually nine
point nine billion but I put ten billion
there it employs about 42,000 people
this industry association keeps track of
that and therefore quarter moving
average growth was eight point four
percent the growth long-term after the
beginning right essentially tracks the
growth in semiconductors right similar
vector industry sure if a dispensed
about 2% of its incoming tools and
sometimes it grows more sometimes it
grows less right they're similar and
artists lasya grew a lot essentially
driven by by memory right by innovations
and flash memory right and so they grew
more than a put four percent but but
long-term the things sort of even out if
you wonder how much of this is analog
and how much is digital the bulk of it
is digital right if you look at the
different categories of the IP the
result five percent is analog of layout
tools twenty four percent or analog and
of the higher level design twenty
percent is so it's about 20 percent of
the tools that are sold are sold for
analog designs right the rest is all
digital if you look at this historically
right this is the sub-segment right the
the interesting thing here of course is
well there's a few things right one is
that this blue line which was the
smallest when we started tracking this
1996 now it's the largest right so
that's IP right intellectual property
and then the reasons very simple as I
said most designs they are put together
if you want to oversimplify it like Lego
blocks you get an arm core you get a USB
right and then
you get all the peripherals that you
want you get a radio right and then you
put all this together you design a
little bit of what is called new logic
so that all the things work together and
you throw in some software because they
all have process of these days right in
the other chip and so M semiconductor IP
is the largest category
the other interesting thing that happens
right is of course at these two which
are M services and PCB didn't grow as
fast as the other ones if that's not
surprising right printed circuit boards
are they are more there are more complex
and they're smaller geometries and they
had ten years ago but nothing even close
to Moore's law right where things were
driven by smaller and smaller geometries
in the semiconductor market that was
growing another really funny thing but
some of you may remember anybody knows
who Joe Costello was and two notes so
Joe Costello was the CEO of cadence
which at the time was the largest EDA
company and the time I'm talking about
is here 2001 2002 right and he had the
vision that EDA companies should really
become service companies he said there's
no point in everybody learning how to
design a chip just give me the spec
write a chip at a high level and I
design it for you and I can design it
better because I've designed a hundred
ships I do it for a living right it's so
you'll never learn how to design chips
Oh God and furthermore I own the tools
right so I kind of know exactly what the
tools do etc and so for a while the
world believed that right and they
thought in the English you become a
service industry as a vision but it
didn't work out right and Joe Costello
left cadence and the industry did not
become service industry it continues to
be a software industry and and as a
matter of fact services right are the
worst performance of this whole thing
right they sort of got stuck there and
people use them but if you wanna
differentiate you better assemble your
own design team and you decide your own
chip right don't outsource this as a
service if you look at this thing from a
geographic point of view right then
not surprisingly right the US continues
to be the largest market then as
everybody would expect asia-pacific
right which includes sort of Korea China
Taiwan which were nowhere to be seen in
96 now is solidly the second largest
segment and may surpass right it
surpassed
perhaps you could argue and this because
intellectual property is difficult to
protect right EDA tools are pirated so
if and this is a big if right there's
more piracy in China than there is in
America you could argue that perhaps
they already surpassed the u.s. in use
of EDA tools right because this is
measured in dollars of course right and
so and but they've become solidly right
the second largest market and then M
Europe and Japan right R which were sort
of the same right are stagnant right
lately Japan is more stagnant than
Europe right and that there's no news
there right and regarding EDA use in
terms of companies right in the market
and the first three there's an office
kailasam mentor are very often referred
to as a big three you can see their
yearly revenues right in the last three
years
Epson office the largest one a little
bit over three billion right cadence
about two billion mentor a little bit
over a billion and a half the other
interest and these are tool companies
right their main business is up redoing
the a tools write they sell software and
the other companies are a little bit
more heterogeneous particularly
ancestors ook an arm is what everybody
know arm arm
everybody knows arm course arm is the
largest provider of IP right every cell
phone has an arm core in there right and
they have done very well as you can see
answers is a company that specializes in
simulation software so they in addition
to EDA they sell electromagnetic
simulation they sell fluid dynamic
simulation right all these things
need an engineering reducing adjacent
filament so not everything that is in
there is used for four circuits right
and Zhu ken is a Japanese company which
does essentially printed circuit board
software right and so and that's the
thing if you put the thing in
perspective EDA I told you is ten
billions right this is the inverse peer
I mean the other interesting industry
that is as to the base of semiconductors
is the equipment industry right these
are the ASM else and KL 810 core Applied
Materials they know the machines that
you need in a fab to actually fabricate
the circuit so they sell about sixty
billion dollars a year
EDA does the tools that you need to
design the chips right they sell about
ten billion a year on top of this you
have a semiconductor industry which is
about four words there's four sixty five
billion right last four quarters running
the semiconductor industry association
tracks these numbers exactly right so
you can tell you can tell so this 70
billion right enable the semiconductor
industry which is four hundred sixty
five billion which in turn enables the
electronic system industry which is
about 1.6 billion there now you have to
take that number with a grain of salt
because it's hard to agree what is the
electronic system some people would say
the whole car is electronic system right
but but that's obviously not there right
where does the electronic stop interests
starts right but this number right four
hundred to one point six over twenty
five percent of the value and an
electronic system if you buy a cell
phone are the chips in it right and the
other three quarters are other things
like batteries displays printed circuit
boards who knows what right that's it
that's it now if you put that in
perspective with high-tech right the EDA
industry is a very small industry right
and ten billion dollars for the 2004
years that's about two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars per employee if you go
to Facebook right 40 billion dollars
revenue only twenty five
thousand employees right that's about
two million dollars per employee you 128
right so they do perhaps ten times
better right eight times better right
ETA in terms of in terms of productivity
right Microsoft pretty good right about
a million dollars per employee hundred
and ten billion dollars with 110,000
employees Google similar to Microsoft
right same size right fewer a little
fewer employees and but same order of
magnitude right Apple doing very well
right one hundred twenty three thousand
per unit twice as much money as
Microsoft we're a little bit more than
that right and if you look at
semiconductors overall is 465 billion
they employ 1.1 million dollars I guess
I just want to put that in perspective
right this is a very small industry in
high-tech but an absolutely vital one
right if you know if the software tools
that you can design chips
the other interesting thing is that it's
very and I think this is part of the
comments right of the self-deprecation
that the industry itself plus all the
time it's a very unproductive industry
if you look at it right I mean the
amount of dollars per employee generated
right is very low in other way of saying
that is it's it's a person power
intensive so there's a lot of people
right to do what they do and one of the
consequences if you look at the thing is
that there's a lot of PDA outfits and
low-cost geographies so places like
Armenia right has thousands and
thousands of people working in India and
you would never suspect that our meanie
as a hard to country but but but that is
what it is right this even country that
I originally come from Chile two days to
EDA outfits right both mental graphics
and synopsis right there's a few people
there right so they are in low-cost
economies for this reason lots of
manpower needed so before I end with
this I want to give you a brief
historical overview of
I always enjoy history because that is
what puts things in perspective and
given that this is fairly new it started
in the 60s right the integrated circuit
was invented in 59 or 60 depending on
how you look at it Rights is fairly new
industry and this good records of the
history yes so you can reconstruct it
right and so am initially right in the
60s where you're doing circuits with a
few transistors right one or two or
three transistors right an or gate
perhaps something like that right and
these circuits were done by cutting Ruby
leaves where there's some kind of
plastic and so you generate the mass put
the thing in a machine right shine light
on a wafer that was coated pretty much
by hand right with some photographic
resist right that would edge some people
saw you put it in some acid that would
edge something on and do some wet
deposits so that some aluminum got in
the places that you aged or you didn't
etch it so on and so forth it was it was
a hand process right there's no
automation whatsoever right and people
the engineers right where we're doing
the whole thing in 1964 the electronic
design out to me and and people of
course understood that you wanted to
automate that right so people writing
little programs right on HP calculators
that would calculate a the gain of an
op-amp or something like that right had
been around forever and and so people
knew that this couldn't continue
so 1964 the first design automation
conference happened and that is sort of
the official date earth of EDA and the
next thing that happened is that this
cutting Ruby leaf became just too
complicated and so given that printers
were around right Calma and up lakorn
did some workstations that allow you to
digitize right they had this digitizer
things right where you could draw
essentially the same thing that you were
cutting before and the thing would print
them and so you could use this printed
thing you would print on Ruby leaf so
I'd like to remember well some of you
may write you used to print slides right
projection slices have to be what I'm
doing here you're going to slide that
you shone light
so you could print the things right and
so that was the first automation of two
companies Talman applicant which used
many computers of the day deck and data
general right and so the thing as a
workstation so the business model of
this companies was they would sell your
workstation that allowed you to digitize
the thing and then Berkeley invented
spies which is essentially circuit
simulation based on neural analysis and
later on modified Knoll analysis and
around the same time IBM Yorktown
Heights did a stop which is a competitor
to spies which nobody knows right based
on tableau analysis but they use it
internally right it's om you could now
simulate the things that we were going
to build right and get an idea of what
the performance is without without
having to actually fabricate them and
this was the era of the designer that
was called the tall thin man right it
was so tall and thin because you had to
know a little bit of everything this is
where you were tall but you know a lot
about anything right that's where you
were thin and so M designers were tall
thin man that had to know everything
right from circuit Theory how transistor
behaves how do I run spies right to how
do i digitize things on a tablet right
to to layout right all the way from
circuit to layout to implementation and
then in 1979 this remarkable book came
out right introduction to VLSI systems
everybody cites it right cover me Dylan
Conway and they made the on those days
revolutionary claim that you don't need
to know a lot about fabrication right
and you can design integrated circuits
anyway and they use the things you see
here called stick diagrams right which
which so it was a high light slightly
higher level of obstructions and are
probably drawing the transistor draw
sticks this is metal this is Paulie
right and this is the gate and so on and
so forth nm and with that right they
essentially started the soul revolution
semiconductors
end of the twelfth and man the
separation of fabrication from design
right and today that's the way it is
right I mean and there is a few holdouts
left like Intel right and and and then
the memory companies but our bubbly
memories are very easy to design they're
hard to manufacture right but but it's
one design once you have to sell that's
it right you just replicate the thing
but Intel is of course an integrated
design manufacture they have the fab and
they design things right for the rest
the industry is essentially separated
right if you look at Qualcomm Nvidia
Broadcom right most of the companies
they design the things and then somebody
else fabricate sobriety so this is the
origin of that right that you don't have
to be tall and thin anymore you can know
exactly what you're doing and so the
next step that came along was around
1981 Daisy mental graphics and valid
logic which were acronym the DMV right
the Department of Motor Vehicles and all
launched in parallel right this
schematic and layout editors which now
allowed you to design circuits not by
drawing them remember we were simulating
they've been drawing them now you could
actually use a logic editor or a layout
a little right you could draw
transistors connect transistors and the
things then would be converted in a
layout and be layout kind of in a
semi-automatic way you could move them
by hand right and and connect them right
and so em design moved and now the way
to design a circuit and you could do
things with hundreds of transistors
right what schematic capture right so
you would have either transistors or
logic gates and you draw the things and
that's how still taught in IE classes
right I mean that's how you design a
logic circuit and in 1984 that was the
next big step if we keep also track of
the commercial part right the design
automation conference added a tradeshow
right so now we didn't have only a
conference right if
conference the conference also came with
a trade show and in around the end of
the 90s right 1986 and 1988 mentor
managed to do the move right the other
two companies disappeared right these
are all new companies in the generations
and synopsis and cadence came on and
they are still there right there a big
three these are the companies that I
showed you a few minutes ago invented
synthesis and place and route and so
that was the end of schematic capture
for digital design I mean analog design
is still done with schematic capture I
do draw transistors and things like that
right and that that is still there but
digital circuits now are written like
programs right you write a thing in very
look at the RTL level and you compile it
and then the synthesis of converts this
thing into logic optimizes it placement
puts all this gates somewhere on the on
the chip right routing connects them the
way you intend them to do and integrated
chip so I don't have to do up a hand
anymore right and so and that was a huge
innovation in 1989 the industry reaches
a billion dollars in the ad a consortium
which is this ESDA thing where I got all
this numbers from write the lobbying
group of the industry was formed so
another side of maturity arm was founded
in 1990 and it is our very VIP company
right there about Fabrice by far the
largest IP company right and spirit
company right they started in 1990 so IP
which is the other big segment that is
out there right came along the industry
tagged along right growing nicely two
three four billion dollars by 2019
ninety nine in retrospect that's easy to
say right that attendance peaked at
about 20,000 people right and that was
not the end of it but the peak of it
then a few years later about ten years
ago right 207 208 it's hard to pinpoint
exactly right then our scaling ended
right and that essentially ended Moore's
law and since then we have been
struggling right
and when I showed you before so that's
the history of EDA in a nutshell what we
can do and if I want to summarize it
today right we can design four billion
transistors I can design 40 million
transistors if you want right but I'm
gonna be conservative at a cost of
roughly 50 million dollars takes about a
year you need a team of a hundred people
if you want to do something of this
complexity I mean maybe 200 300 maybe 50
right you know what you're doing but
that's the order of magnitude and if you
compare that to something else right
from mechanical engineering which is of
course much less standardized right when
I say we have 4 billion transistors well
this perhaps 20 different kinds there
right so there are you mark doubly
standardized if I look at the 4 million
parts right in air both 380 you write
this probably a few thousand per 10,000
different parts right they are they're
not the same obviously but the number of
parts that we have right is is is a
thousand times bigger right in in EDA
right the development cost is 28 billion
right so it's five hundred six I'm
bigger than developing a chip
the development time is about 10 years
right takes 10 years to develop Lane
even more right and the teams are of the
order of 10,000 people right so it's
hundred X right so there's a very nice
illustration I think to show you what
standardization and automatisation can
do right and and and you have to because
of course using a methodology like this
there's no way right you're going to and
to do a thing thousand times bigger
right and the a380s the end of it right
and unless something changes is not P
airplanes that are a hundred times
bigger or whatever like that right with
that methodology right so EDA ASM is has
been an extremely successful right and
judged by that and so let me finish now
with a few new things right what's new
what has been happening what are the
trends in media in the last years right
and and and why is that important
right so electronic system design ESL
which also called high level design
right essentially instead of writing
your circuit and very lock which is this
RTL where your model is you know what
happens in every cycle you write them in
something like C++ right where you have
data structures and and heaps and piles
and stacks and who knows what right in
objects right and and abstractions that
are at much higher level and electronic
system level design right it's a little
bit bigger than logic synthesis for the
first time if you look at this 13 years
ago right it was only half as big and
this half was essentially all
verification because when when you
design a new chip right in you typically
want an architectural model of the thing
and what most people do is they write
some kind of program right that
simulates instructions or function at
some level right and so these were
mainly tools for that right not for
synthesis right and so that has come
into its own as a matter of fact if you
look into FPGAs and FPGAs are mostly
design like that right you can all FPGA
system and these are the two big ones
right this is Tara and the stylings
right they all start with C design right
or C++ design right and you compile the
thing down until UK general a bit stream
that goes into the field programmable
gate array and you don't design the
things are single gates anymore right
now arguably of course this is a special
kind of computer and you could say this
is a special kind of compiler but that's
the whole point right I mean you can you
can design something much more efficient
than code that is going to run on a
general-purpose computer right meaning
the bit streams to program in FPGA
essentially writing the same software
than you would write to for a program
and if you take this one step further
there's a lot of hardware either out
there already like the tensile
processing unit from Google right and
they do this TPU parts or I didn't and
they put them up in data centers right
and you can access it things in the
cloud
and so em if your application that you
have happens to run on the thing right
and and this is essentially a simplified
fpga that does one thing very well which
is multiply accumulates right if you
look at the architecture right all they
do is that this is multiple accumulates
to solve linear algebra problems right
and so that's that's one that's this
right you can actually use tensor flow
you can use Python you can use cafe I
mean if you use all this high level
things where I just write them and then
eventually have them running in a very
very efficient way right understand on
the spots that are in the web so if you
look also now at the FPGA design systems
and we use the things in in our class
and they are starting to write front
ends that are higher level than C so
that you can sort of design your own
accelerator right for your application
in an FPGA essentially writing the thing
in pencil flow or in Python or whatever
you want to do the a tendancy number to
write is of course IP right in in in
nineteen in 2005 it was nineteen percent
and today 36 percent right and that is
epitomized by the acquisition of ARM arm
was acquired by Softbank
in 2016 for 32 billion dollars their
revenue was about half of synopsis and
cadence you know what the valuation of
cadence was in those days and synopsis
you may know it was about eight billion
dollars right so they got a pre before
four times for half right over them and
they're only half the revenue right and
and that's because everybody knew that
this is going to continue growing number
one and number two is also because of a
business model so EDA software is sold
as a subscription so they made that
transition so you don't buy it and keep
it right you do it like everybody else
does it these days so you get a
subscription so every year you're a new
user
so it is a nicely a nice revenue stream
IP right they touch a little bit up
front and then they charge a royalty per
chip so if Apple buys an arm core and
puts an iPhone and they produce a
billion iPhones they get a million times
a royalty right which is a much better
much better particularly if you
customers are successful business model
than just charging a subscription for
idea to royalty right for every chip
that you pour out because it's now
coming there we want to check a little
bit so we grew they grew very very
nicely and if you look up there EDA
tools for doing this why type
integrations everywhere if you go to the
synopsis website right they say you have
a design database and yeah there's a
netlist there that's your design on top
there but everything else is IP heart
macros soft macros memories IP library
stand ourselves i/o sets right these are
all different forms of IP somebody
designed that you put in the library and
then you use it right and then some of
the things you're royalty some things
don't allow it is right but you need a
lot of IP right I mean starting with
simple cells right if you have an on
sale in or so you're not going to design
an entrepreneur from scratch or a
library right and that's there all the
way up to an ant core and if you look at
the FPGA guys why they have this MIP
integrators and the thing starts looking
so specially close to a netlist again
right only to necklace at it or only the
blocks are big IP blocks right they are
not a gate or a transistor right this is
like a whole chip and the third trend
rather I want to see is increased chip
design activity what is that why is that
important because at the end of the day
the the money spent on EDA right is R&D
money right the services design money
right research and development
development money and so it's very
important when an inverter is young
right in this from ICN sites you spend a
lot on our MD when an industry becomes
mature you spent very little on our end
right and so the strength essentially
happened here right this is the R&D
expenditures from IBM so these are the
incomes of the world so it includes
things for fabs of course but it also
includes things right for fabulous trip
suppliers right and and also for pure
clay foundries which are facts right
they manufacture so this is the
aggregate of what you spent in designing
chips and manufacturing chips right and
that has been going down down down right
but now I'm remarkably right it's
picking up again right and the reason
that is picking up is that we have all
these new applications and one of the
most important one is of course
artificial intelligence so for whatever
reason this got frozen yeah yeah and so
and if you look at chip startups right
the New York Times published an article
in 2017 1.5 billion of venture capital
money was invested in chip startups
right when as I told you - yes earlier
right this number was very very small
right it was a hundred flowers in there
hundreds of millions right and that is
essentially to a large extent right to
do - for a few things right AI but also
IOT right or another way of looking at
it is the data center is essentially
increasingly AI centric right that's
what's new of course there's a lot of
traditional applications as well but and
but there's all these new companies that
are trying to come up with the next
standard if there is one right for AI
kind of applications and there isn't
surprising amount of money right graph
core which did this big chip with 20
plus billion that I showed you in the
beginning right they rest raised three
hundred and ten million dollars yeah
they're British company but there's
others that have risen 200 million in
this some very small startups righty
there's many more like this
it's election some of these and that is
interests are actually analog music for
example when so em all computers have
they well not all but the vast majority
of computers right are digital when
you're doing artificial intelligence and
the accuracy is not that important what
we know multiplying you're multiplying a
wait times something observed right the
intensity of a pixel or something like
that if you do that an analog right you
can essentially we don't want transistor
and you don't need a complicated
multiplier and who knows what right so
some of them are trying to relate an
analog with it works or not is another
question but they have raised money so
and that is that in terms of course
burns investments in EDA tools or the
startups the tools right etc etc not
only startups but also traditional
companies whoever you look at they have
an effort nai
right companies that traditionally don't
design chips also known as efforts right
Alibaba Google and so on and so forth
they're all designing chips right and
obviously the traditional IP vendors in
the EDA companies right they're also
developing course right new design so
this is all new development which which
of course requires tools and so with
that since we're talking AI right I
think that that's a good segue for the
last two minutes or three minutes that
I'm going to spend right one is a plug
for EE 292 a it's a class that we give
here right that that essentially focuses
on understanding the inner workings of
the tool but with an emphasis of using
them so we don't think that it's going
to be a whole generation of people
designing new tools but if you really
want to write a good program you need to
understand what a compiler does if you
man is an ego chip you need to
understand what this series of 30 tools
actually do and and that's what we teach
there right and then we have a lab where
we design a convolutional neural network
with does image recognition in its first
incarnation last year with it sort of a
very small digit recognition thing this
year with
something slightly more complicated
right so this is a convolutional neural
network right and it's a bunch of layers
and essentially all the things are doing
is multiplying matrices of different
sizes right so there's a lot of multiply
accumulate and there's a lot to play
there with the architecture right you
can vary the accuracy and then see if
the thing still recognizes the same way
we're using eight pages and four
sixteen bits right you can and play of
course with the number of multiplex
units that you have which sort of will
change your memory strategy how do you
are how do you store intermediate
results right it obviously the more
Hardware you have the faster it's going
to execute if you have less hard core
right you have to sort of figure out how
to schedule things right and so on so
forth so this is a very nice application
actually to to learn how to do all the
strain offs that you do when you design
something the implementation the first
time around was done in a intel fpga
board which had which has in a terra
fpga intel bottle Tara right and it was
written OpenCL and then essentially the
thing gets synthesized onto an
accelerator right which the whole sort
of sees as a peripheral so pretty much
the same way than your your computer
sees your GPU you're in video card as an
accelerator you can run tensorflow on
the things right you are designing the
accelerator that will run your
particular application on the
accelerator right and you can write
software around it on a regular computer
this year we are considering to use a
silence flow right they have slightly
higher level right so you can write
things all the way up to tensorflow
right and then this whole thing gets
compiled to an FPGA and again the idea
is of course to do all this trade-offs
in hardware right what accelerates what
how fast is it how big is it how much
power does it use right you have to
understand these things very well and
the last plug is for silicon catalyst
right we are partly there were an
incubator for solutions with silicon so
if you want to do a chip there's an
interesting place to start because like
every incubator of course we select
companies so we
everybody but then what's different it's
an incubation last 24 months and not
three months like software incubator
because designing a chip takes time and
the second really interesting thing is
that we have this in-kind partners so
instead of getting money from us you get
synopsis tools thank you very much you
get some wafer runs at the SMC right you
get advantage to test your chip right if
you need instruments you get you can
lease for a very low price keysight
instruments right and so on and so forth
we have over 20 income partners that
give what you need to design a trip
either for free or at a very low cost to
the startups and that was safety of the
order of a million or two million
dollars which you would have to spend
otherwise to buy all the things so for
two years you get that for free and you
know to negotiate with all this company
so I the incubator is standing for you
and so and it had the other nice thing
is that during the selection process you
got in front of experts from all these
companies right and so if you've been
there and and you get feedback right and
if you get selected you know that you've
got selected by experts in the
semiconductor industry right all our
advisers all the people that participate
in the selection process right are of
the industry at half and experienced and
so and the store the histories and we
have review since 2015 450 company we
have selected and 19 right here are our
portfolio companies right there this I
mean I won't go through all of them
that's too much but we have computer
companies like Rex right and this is an
AI company that does intelligence on be
on the edge and the first were there is
a photonics company which aims at
putting the transducers in silicon the
electric photonic transduces is silicon
right we have some biotech companies
right and like probe's DX right and so
on and so forth a bunch of wireless
companies that want to do very very low
power communication for em for IOT at
the edge right etc etc and and the thing
in common here is that the
designing chips or FPGAs or plan to do
that at some point in their time and so
if you want to get the tools and get
some advice right that's a good place to
start this is just a distribution in
case you're curious right I mean of
course by far because we're in Silicon
Valley right most companies crammed from
you look up there from Silicon Valley
and from California and from the US
right but we have one companies
Singapore one a few companies in Canada
right and this is a few outside of the
u.s. most technology use right is 28 to
130 nanometers 28 nanometer is still
kind of the workhorse of the industry
it's already pretty expensive right most
company starts with 40 nanometers 45 or
something around there most of them are
doing a six if you are doing analog
memory or other things right but in a
six-digit ultra wide application
specific integrated circuits and then
IOT mobile industrial and data center
right that covers the four applications
that are most common and so with that
let me end right hardware design is
exciting again EDA is what's enabling it
right and EDA has gone through a
profound transformation actually the old
dream of a silicon compiler things to IP
big blocks right which is like libraries
safeword again
then in software right and high-level
design right which is copulation right
makes it possible to design really
really complex chips thank you